>>> THE COUNTRY WAITS TO SEE HOW
MUCH OF THE MAA-LAGO SEARCH
AFFIDAVIT COULD BE MADE PUBLIC
ON THURSDAY.
OTHER DOCUMENTS NOW PUBLICLY
SHARPEN THE FOCUS ON DONALD
TRUMP AS THE POSSIBLE SUBJECT OF
A CRIMINAL CODE.
THAT'S WHAT LEGAL EXPERTS ARE
TELLING CNN.
A PROCEDURAL DOCUMENT UNSEALED
THURSDAY TALKS ABOUT WILLFUL
INTERFERENCE WITH A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
WITH ME TO TALK ABOUT THAT,
DANIEL LITMAN, CNN POLITICAL
ANALYST, AND LAURA LOPEZ, WHITE
HOUSE CORRESPONDENT FOR THE PBS
NEWS HOUR.
GUYS, THANK YOU FOR COMING IN ON
A SATURDAY NIGHT.
DANIEL, THERE ARE SIGNS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WILL TRY AND
USE THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH AS A
STARTING POINT FOR A POTENTIAL
2024 CAMPAIGN.
DO YOU EXPECT THE TIMING OF THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT OR AN ANNOUNCEMENT
IF HE DOES RUN, WHICH HAS BEEN A
HOT BUTTON ISSUE, EVERYBODY IS
TALKING ABOUT IT IN TOWN, DO YOU
EXPECT IT TO MOVE UP, TO MOVE
BACK?
>> WHAT WE'RE HEARING IS IT'S
PROBABLY GOING TO BE MOVED TO
AFTER THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
IF HE ANNOUNCES BEFORE AND THEN
REPUBLICANS DO HORRIBLY IN TERMS
OF NOT TAKING OVER THE SENATE,
THEN REPUBLICANS COULD CAST
BLAME AT TRUMP AND SAY, HEY, YOU
MESSED IT UP, YOU REALLY RALLIED
DEMOCRATS IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THAT THERE'S A KIND OF A
RALLY ROUND BIDEN EFFECT.
TRUMP IS A BETE NOIR IN THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
>> REPUBLICAN LEADERS HAVE ASKED
HIM TO WAIT.
LAURA, SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HAD
A REALLY GOOD STORY ABOUT HOW
REPUBLICANS WHO ARE RUNNING IN
TIGHT RACES, PARTICULARLY IN THE
HOUSE, KIND OF AVOID MENTIONING
TRUMP ALTOGETHER AS THE
MID-TERMS GET CLOSER.
ONE REPUBLICAN LAWMAKER TELLING
CNN, QUOTE, I DON'T SAY HIS NAME
EVER.
IF TRUMP DOES JUMP INTO THE 2024
RACE SOONER RATHER THAN LATER AS
GOP LEADERS HAVE ASKED HIM NOT
TO DO, WILL REPUBLICANS HAVE TO
MAKE THIS ALL ABOUT TRUMP?
>> I THINK A LOT OF THE RACES
ALREADY ARE ALL ABOUT TRUMP.
SO MANY OF THE NEW REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES WHO WON THEIR
PRIMARIES WHO ARE NOW THE GOP
NOMINEES WON BECAUSE THEY
TETHERED THEMSELVES TO TRUMP,
BECAUSE THEY PARROTED THE 2020
ELECTION LIES.
WE'VE HAD THOSE ANONYMOUS QUOTES
LIKE WAS IN THE CNN ARTICLE,
BECAUSE AGAIN, PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO DISTANCE THEMSELVES FROM HIM
SO FAR ARE NOT PUTTING REALLY
THEIR NAMES TO IT, OTHER THAN
THE ONES THAT WE KNOW ALREADY,
WHICH IS LIZ CHENEY AND ADAM
KINZINGER.
>> WE'RE ON YEAR SEVEN OF THE
TERROR OF GOING ON THE RECORD TO
CRITICIZE THE PRESIDENT.
DANIEL, YOU TALK ABOUT FOLKS
THAT TRUMP HAS BACKED.
HERE IS WHAT MITCH McCONNELL
SAID IN APRIL ABOUT THE
MIDTERMS.
QUOTE, OBVIOUSLY THE ATMOSPHERE
COULD NOT BE BETTER.
I THINK IT IS AN OVERWHELMING
LIKELIHOOD THE WIND WILL BE AT
OUR BACK AND THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
VERY IMPORTANT.
I WANT TO SHARE WHAT McCONNELL
SAID THIS WEEK.
>> I THINK THERE IS PROBABLY A
GREATER LIKELIHOOD THE HOUSE
FLIPS THAN THE SENATE.
CANDIDATE QUALITY HAS A LOT TO
DO WITH THE OUTCOME.
>> THE FIRST PART IS JUST A
FACT, RIGHT?
THERE IS A GREATER LIKELIHOOD
THE HOUSE FLIPS THAN THE SENATE.
THE CANDIDATE QUALITY COMMENT,
MITCH McCONNELL WATCHES HIS
WORDS VERY CLOSELY.
HE'S NOT LOOSE WITH WHAT HE'S
SAYING THERE.
AND WHAT HE WAS ALLUDING TO I
THINK HAS A LOT OF TRUTH TO SOME
DEGREE.
IS HE LOWERING EXPECTATIONS
THERE, KIND OF EMBRACING A
REALITY RIGHT NOW FOR REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES IN THE SENATE?
>> I THINK IT'S A COMBINATION OF
BOTH.
HE'S KIND OF THROWING THOSE
HERSCHEL WALKERS, MEHMET OZES,
UNDER THE BUS.
THESE ARE NOT CANDIDATES HE
NECESSARILY WANTED, IN TERMS OF
ENTERTAINMENT AND SPORTS STARS,
THOSE ARE NOT THE TYPES OF PIMA
CONNELL LIKES TO SURROUND
HIMSELF WITH IN THE SENATE.
THEY'RE UNTESTED.
PARTICULARLY IN GEORGIA, YOU
LOOK AT THE NEGATIVE ADS FROM
HIS EX-WIFE ACCUSING HIM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, AND IN
PENNSYLVANIA, WHERE YOU HAVE DR.
OZ COMMITTING GAFFE AFTER GAFFE.
YOU WONDER WHO ON THE CAMPAIGN
IS SAYING, YES, IT'S A GOOD IDEA
TO POST VIDEOS OF HIM TALKING
ABOUT FRENCH, YOU KNOW, CUISINE
PLATTERS.
>> CRUDITES.
>> A GOT AN EMAIL FROM
MERRIAM-WEBSTER SAYING THAT WAS
ONE OF THE TOP-SEARCHED WORDS
THIS WEEK.
THAT'S PROBABLY NOT A GOOD --
WHEN YOU'RE GOING VIRAL FOR
THAT, YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT DOING
THAT WELL IN YOUR CAMPAIGN.
>> IT'S INTERESTING ISSUE, IT'S
FASCINATING BECAUSE OF TRUMP AND
McCONNELL'S ABILITY TO COME IN
AND DOMINATE WHO IS RUNNING AND
WHO THE PARTY GETS BEHIND HAS
BEEN SHIFTED TO SOME DEGREE IN
THIS CYCLE.
BUT THE IDEA THAT YOU'RE GETTING
AT THERE IN TERMS OF MIDTERM
RACES, ONE WE'VE BEEN WATCHING A
TON FOR A GOOD REASON IS
PENNSYLVANIA.
A TOSSUP STATE, REPUBLICANS
THOUGHT THEY HAD A CHANCE TO
HOLD IT, DEMOCRATS SAW A PICKUP
OPPORTUNITY.
DR. MEHMET OZ, WHO TRUMP
ENDORSED, DEMOCRAT JOHN
FETTERMAN, OZ IS CATCHING GRIEF
FOR THE VERY CAMPAIGN VIDEO
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHICH
TAUGHT EVERYBODY WHAT CRUDITE
ACTUALLY WAS.
>> I'M DOING GROCERY SHOPPING AT
WEGNER'S AND MY WIFE WANTS SOME
VEGETABLES FOR CRUDITE.
THERE'S BROCCOLI, A TON OF
BROCCOLI THERE, TWO BUCKS.
ASPARAGUS, $4.
CARROTS, THAT'S $4 MORE.
THAT'S $10 OF VEGETABLES THERE.
THEN WE NEED SOME GUACAMOLE,
THAT'S $4 MORE.
>> NOW, OZ WAS DOING THE AD TO
HIGHLIGHT INFLATION, WHICH EVERY
POLL YOU LOOK AT RIGHT NOW SAYS
IT'S THE NUMBER ONE CONCERN FOR
AMERICANS.
CRUDITE SEEMS TO BE THE ISSUE
THAT HAS CAUSED A LOT OF ANGST.
WITH FETTERMAN CAPITALIZING,
PATROLLING OZ ON ANYTHING FROM
SAYING "CRUDITE," INSTEAD OF
"VEGGIE TRAY," CONFUSING THE
NAME OF TWO SUPERMARKET CHAINS
IN PENNSYLVANIA, AND THERE'S
EVEN A REPORT IN "ROLLING STONE"
THAT TRUMP THINKS OZ WILL
BLEEPING LOSE WITHOUT SOME
DRASTIC CHANGES.
YOU LOOK AT THE POLLING COMING
OUT, THINGS ARE KICKING INTO
GEAR.
IS OZ IN REAL TROUBLE RIGHT NOW?
>> I THINK THAT'S BLINDINGLY
OBVIOUS.
IF YOU LOOK AT PENNSYLVANIA,
JOHN FETTERMAN HAS NOT BEEN ABLE
TO CAMPAIGN FOR THE LAST FEW
MONTHS BECAUSE HE IS RECOVERING
FROM HIS STROKE.
AND DR. OZ HAS BEEN CAMPAIGNING
A BUNCH THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT
HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO HAVE THAT
REAL MAN, EVERYDAY TOUCH.
HE HAS A TV STAR.
AND WITH TRUMP'S ELECTION IN
2016, A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
ON TV ARE SAYING, HEY, I WANT TO
DO THAT TOO.
DR. OZ IS CLOSE TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
BUT THIS WEEK HE ALSO HAD ISSUES
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF HOUSES
HE HAS, THE NUMBER OF
RESIDENCES.
THAT HARKENS BACK TO, MOST
AMERICANS CAN SAY, THEY HAVE ONE
HOUSE, MAYBE A BEACH HOUSE THEY
GO TO FOR A TIMESHARE AT BEST.
AND SO IT KIND OF COMES INTO THE
MITT ROMNEY TERRITORY OF -- AND
JOHN McCAIN, WHERE THEY GOT IN
TROUBLE FOR THEIR WEALTH.
>> LAURA, I WANT TO KIND OF RIDE
OFF THAT A LITTLE BIT TO THE
PLACE WE GENERALLY ARE MOST
DAYS, WHICH IS THE WHITE HOUSE.
NOT AN INSTITUTION, NOT A TEAM
KNOWN FOR THE MEMES, DIGITAL IS
NOT THEIR FOCUS IN THE CAMPAIGN,
THEY EMBRACE THAT TO SOME
DEGREE.
BUT BIDEN HAS CAUGHT A LOT OF
BREAKS AFTER A DIFFICULT YEAR,
HIS TEAM IS EMBRACING THIS WHOLE
DARK BRANDON MEME, WHICH
BASICALLY TAKES AN INSULT USED
AGAINST HIM BY CONSERVATIVES, A
RATHER CRUDE ONE, AND TURNS IT
AROUND ON HIS CRITICS.
LOOK IT UP, IT TAKES A LOT OF
TIME TO DISCUSS.
HE'S GOT A STYLE SECTION ARTICLE
ABOUT THIS.
THIS SEEMS TRIVIAL AND KIND OF
WEIRD "INSIDE THE BELTWAY" BUT
IT REFLECTS A FEELING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT I'VE PICKED UP,
A TEAM THAT WAS HAVING A TOUGH
TIME AND FELT LIKE THINGS
WEREN'T EVER GOING TO BREAK
THEIR WAY AND THERE'S ALMOST,
DARE I SAY, A SWAGGER ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE APPROACHING THINGS.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE STAFF IS
FEELING THEMSELVES, THEY'RE
PRETTY HAPPY ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING, BECAUSE OF COURSE
BIDEN JUST GOT ONE OF THE
BIGGEST WINS HE HAD BEEN PUSHING
FOR FOR OVER A YEAR, WHICH WAS
ACTUALLY PASSING SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE IN THAT BUILD
BACK BETTER PLAN, THE CLIMATE
CHANGE, THE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
REFORM, WHICH DEMOCRATS HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN TRYING TO GET FOR
SOME 20-ODD YEARS.
SO THOSE ARE THINGS THAT HE NOW
GETS TO SAY, LOOK, WHEN I WAS
PRESIDENT, WE WERE ABLE TO DO
THIS IN ADDITION TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILLS.
BUT TO YOUR POINT, PHIL, THIS
WHITE HOUSE, THROUGHOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN, WHEN HE WAS A
CANDIDATE, THROUGHOUT HIS
CAMPAIGN, THEY ALWAYS, YOU KNOW,
WERE HAPPY ABOUT THE FACT AND
PRIDED THEMSELVES ON THE FACT
THAT TWITTER IS NOT THE REAL
WORLD AND WE DON'T ENGAGE IN
TWITTER.
AND NOW THEY'RE ACTUALLY USING
THESE VIRAL MEMES TO SHOW, LOOK,
WE HAVE A PEP IN OUR STEP AND
WE'RE GOING ON OFFENSE.
AND THEY ARE ABOUT TO REALLY HIT
THE GAS ON, THEY SAY THE
PRESIDENT IS ABOUT TO FINALLY
ACTUALLY MAKE A LOT OF TOUR
TRIPS AROUND THE COUNTRY TO PUSH
WHAT HE'S ACCOMPLISHED AND TO
TRY TO GET OUT THERE AHEAD OF
THE MIDTERMS.
SO WE'LL SEE IF THEY ACTUALLY DO
THAT NOW, ESPECIALLY SINCE HE'S
COMING OFF OF COVID.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK, YEAH, COULD POTENTIALLY
BE GOOD FOR DEMOCRATS.
THEY'RE STARTI